jetzt aber endlich mal eine gute
Nachricht es ist Winter und trotzdem
spricht kaum einer über Corona Bayern
kippt sogar die maskenpflicht also
Krankenhäuser und Arztpraxen sind
trotzdem überlastet aber endlich mal aus
anderen Gründen
ja normale Grippe
Erkältungswelle plus das RS Virus unter
dem vor allem Kinder leiden vor genau
diese Entwicklung waren Experten seit
Monaten und jetzt ist es halt passiert
angespannt sei die Lage in der
Leverkusener Kinderklinik sagt
Klinikdirektor Joachim Eichhorn an einer
Stelle muss er während unseres
Interviews dennoch lachen bei der Frage
nach freien Betten also frei
ein freies Bett es steht da drüben
hinter dem Einhorn vor dem Yeti
tatsächlich waren neulich nur noch 83
Intensivbetten für Kinder frei im ganz
Deutschland da wurden kleine Patienten
teilweise 150 Kilometer durch die
Republik gekannt tja blöd gelaufen für
die Arme Conny ja das passiert
das passiert wenn man in den letzten 30
Jahren rund ein Drittel der Kinderbetten
abbaut vom Personalmangel mal ganz zu
schweigen deshalb hat Karl Lauterbach
jetzt angeregt es könnte doch Personal
von anderen Stationen bei den Kindern
einspringen die kam das so an jetzt mal
ganz ehrlich im Handling mit Kindern
kenne ich mich nicht aus ich kann die
nicht versorgen und das ist de facto
einfach so also das da kann ich nichts
machen ich sehe mich da nicht als Hilfe
ja ich sehe mich da nicht als Hilfe
exakt das habe ich immer gesagt wenn
meine Frau wollte dass ich auch mal das
Baby Wicke
ich habe mich einfach nicht als Hilfe
gesehen der Pflege hat aber natürlich
völlig recht kinder sind keine kleinen
Erwachsene egal was philipp am Tor uns
glauben lässt
die medizinische Versorgung in dem
Bereich ist hochspezialisiert na klar
wenn gar kein anderes Personal da ist
dann müssen halt mal Quereinsteiger ran
dann operiert hat mal also nicht der
Hausmeister oder
der Krankenhaus klauen ja natürlich
ist das eckart von Hirschhausen
in der Kindermedizin baden Sie jetzt die
Fehler der letzten Jahrzehnte aus weil
Kinder Medizin sich so lange nicht
gerechnet hat warum ist das medial kein
größerer Aufreger warum gibt das kein
größeren Aufschrei ach ja weil Kinder
keine Lobby haben die haben mir nicht
meine eigene heute show bitte doch
hallo unser Gesundheitssystem hat
zuletzt vor einem alten Menschen
geschützt und jetzt für Kinder kein Geld
mehr frei da so folgender Hinweis ich
zahle mir später mal die Rente für das
Hier und meine Generation sollten wir
Ihnen die wegfahren wechseln ist jetzt
wirklich nicht als Drohung gemeint aber
wir können es auch sein lassen denk mal
darüber nach guten Abend
[Musik]
bin mir nicht sicher hat die kleine
Bratze mir gerade gedroht
egal personell ist die Lage im deutschen
Gesundheitssystem tatsächlich wieder
sehr angespannt schon wieder immerhin
hat die Ampel den Ernst der Lage erkannt
Lauterbach spendiert 300 Millionen
zusätzlich für Kinderkliniken und 120
Millionen für die Geburtshilfe und dann
verkündet er diese Woche auch noch eine
große
krankenhausreform ach was Reform viel
geiler ich glaube es ist nicht
übertrieben wenn man sagt das ist der
Beginn einer Revolution in der Art und
Weise wie wir Krankenhäuser
organisieren hurra ja
chill Lauterbach ruft die Revolution aus
Revolution ist für ihn wahrscheinlich
schon wenn der Mann halbes Salzkorn auf
sein frühstückseif streut
tatsächlich ist seine Revolution wenn
man genau hinguckt mehr ein
revolutionchen die blöden Fallpauschalen
bleiben nämlich aber immerhin kriegen
Krankenhäuser dann auch Geld für
Leistungen die sie vorhalten also für
Infrastruktur die nicht so lukrativ ist
wie sagen wir mal eine Hüft-OP aber
trotzdem lebenswichtig wenn der
Gesetzentwurf denn so durchkommt aktuell
bleibt erstmal bei Personalmangel und
bei rappelvollen Wartezimmer alle
medizinischen Fachangestellten bekommen
am Wochenende ein dskalationstraining
dafür hat die Praxis eine Psychologin
eingeladen
liebe Güte ja so ist jetzt die Stimmung
in den Wartezimmern du brauchst
deeskalationspsychologen die dann leider
oft von seit Stunden wartenden Omas
verprügelt werden das ist die Realität
die Nerven liegen blank dabei haben wir
aktuell mehr Ärztinnen und Ärzte als je
zuvor das doofe ist nur um einen Arzt
der in Rente geht zu ersetzen brauchst
du laut Schätzungen 1,2 neue weil viele
jüngere Ärzte statt sich in 15 Stunden
Schichten kaputt zu arbeiten ernsthaft
Ansprüche an die sogenanntes Leben haben
eine komische Generation wirklich so und
auf dem Land finden Sie gar kein Arzt
mehr ist nicht übertrieben Bayern und
NRW haben schon die sogenannte
landarztquote eingeführt mit der kann
man auch ohne einser-abimedizin
studieren muss ich aber im Gegenzug
verpflichten zehn Jahre auf dem Land zu
arbeiten wo man dann wie ein Star
empfangen wird
[Musik]
ein überschwängliches Ständchen für den
neuen Augenarzt in Finsterwalde ja so
kann leider nicht jeder begrüßt werden
der auf dem Land eine Praxis eröffnet
ja es klingt wie so ein alter Heimatfilm
der Augenarzt von Finsterwalde
und in Seesen im Kreis Goslar haben sie
ewig und drei Tage einen neuen
Kinderarzt gesucht weil der nächste viel
zu weit weg war das will man in Seesen
so nicht hinnehmen und geht in die
Offensive
25.000 Euro soll derjenige bekommen der
sich hier als Kinderarzt oder
Kinderärztin niederlässt und der Kreis
Goslar packt noch mal 30.000 € obendrauf
wow 55
000 € Begrüßungsgeld und trotzdem wollte
da keiner hin mein Gott muss das scheiße
sein in Seesen oder
ist Spaß ich war nie da aber für 55
riesen würde ich mir angucken wir haben
heute Medizinstudenten Publikum fällt
mir ein würdet ihr nach Seesen gehen die
winken ab tut mir leid ja
die Generation ich habe es ja gesagt so
bringt die landarztquote die Wände oder
schafft es Karl Lauterbach die
Bundesländer zu überreden 5000 neue
Studienplätze zu schaffen so oder so
Alexander Wipprecht kann darauf als
Dorfbürgermeister nicht mehr warten
[Musik]
stellt sich vor
hallo du bist Allgemeinmediziner und
hast das Stadtleben satt dann kommt zu
uns nach großglöthen Ritze nie wieder
die nervige Frage gehen wir heute zum
Vietnamesen oder zum Italiener hier
geht's jeden Abend in den Gasthof
unsere Erna die ist einfach das Herz und
die Seele unseres Dorfes
unsere Gemeinde hat so viel zu bieten
ohne Ende kostenlose Parkplätze und der
neue Landarzt kriegt selbstverständlich
einen eigenen Dienstwagen
Cabrio ich will nicht lügen der letzte
Bus hat hier irgendwann in den 80ern
gehalten aber lieber Landarzt deine
Kinder gehen trotzdem zur Schule also
wirklich die gehen zum nächsten
Gymnasium sind es gerade mal 18
Kilometer einfach immer geradeaus durch
den Wald und Finn nicht den Würfel in
die Augen schauen ja
die können Angst wittern
hier bei uns in Groß Köthen ritzow
behandelst du endlich wieder richtige
Männerkrankheiten ehrliche Verletzungen
wenn Sie zum Beispiel wieder einer
besoffenens Bein gesägt hat oder auch
mal in den Arm grüß Sie Manfred
das wäre so schön wenn du freiwillig zu
uns kommst nicht wie beim letzten Mal
als wir unser Land als bei einem
Golfturnier ich sag mal angekommen haben
nicht funktioniert leider konnte er noch
einmal halben Jahr fliegen deswegen komm
du jetzt zu uns in eine weltoffene
diverse Gemeinschaft hier ist wirklich
jeder Willkommen ja Moment aber bitte
kein Schuh
wir freuen uns auf DICH bis bald in
großglockende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Alexander Wipprecht
so meine Damen und Herren und nun noch
ein kleiner Sicherheitshinweis unter
Ihrem TV-Gerät hat sich
höchstwahrscheinlich Feuchtigkeit
gebildet wissen Sie die Pfütze mit
Andacht Weg ihr Fernseher weint über den
nahen Tod von Bild TV ja im nächsten
Jahr senden die kaum noch live und das
ist bedauerlich denn der junge Sender
Bild TV hat sich in den letzten Monaten
zu einem unserer wichtigsten
Medienpartner genauso ja ich war vor
allem riesen Fan der Sendung viertel
nach acht glaube ich inzwischen um 10:15
Uhr läuft wie auch immer schön Bild TV
irgendwer mit Medien winkt melancholisch
hinterher
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
gerade erst vorigen Sommer ging an RUB
durch Deutschland die Bild-Zeitung
sollte endlich Fernsehen werden viele
Bauarbeiter ängstigten sich muss ich mir
jetzt den Arsch mit Flachbildschirm
abwischen doch es kam anders statt
röchelnder moderationsmumien bei ARD und
ZDF jung fresh und genau wissen wo die
Kamera steht es ist uns eine große Ehre
dass wir den neuen Sender quasi aus der
Taufe heben dürfen Walldorf von Stettler
sind zusammen ungefähr so alt wie die
Träume die Springer Konzerns ins
Fernsehen zu gehen kurz nach der ersten
Höhlenmalerei in den 60ern wollte
Gründer Axel Caesar das ZDF Geschenk
bekommen in den 80ern Sat.1 und
zwischendurch ständig ProSieben kaufen
nur warum die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen z.B
mit Jan Böhmermann oder der heute Show
machen offiziell Satire eigentlich sind
das inzwischen natürlich wie wir hier
sehen politische Propaganda Sendung Mist
durchschauen höchste Zeit also für einen
Sender der die Sprache des Volkes
spricht
professnelke Vogelscheuche Vollpfosten
und wo ganz normale Menschen im Alter
eine Wärmestube finden journalistisch
überzeugte Springers offene
Selbsthilfegruppe durch konsequenten
Verzicht auf Recherche stattdessen
einfach mal stumpfgerüchte vorlesen und
zwar hat Markus Söder folgendes gesagt
er hat gesagt
Kiste Wasser 2 von Spargel und denk an
deine Zäpfchen Schatz die Methode der
kleine Maulwurf der gar nicht wissen
wollte wer ihm in den Kopf gemacht hat
sorgte für furoren in 13 langen
Programmstunden jeden Tag fand der
Sender eine bisher unbekannte Nähe zum
Publikum etwa in dem er unschuldige
Passanten zur Bratwurst des Jahres
erklärte ich hier neben der Siegerin
unserem Wettbewerb die Bratwurst des
Jahres nämlich Sabrina Hoffmann aus der
Nähe von Kassel ja die freut sich viele
Zuschauer fragten sich begeistert welche
saftbirnen denken sich sowas aus und auf
Platz eins Weihnachtsgebäck des Jahres
von Bild
das saftbirnenbrot von Caroline Scheidle
von der Bäckerei Scheidle
lecker während Oma Scheidle jetzt bis
ans Ende ihrer Tage die Birne entsaftet
erfrischt Bild live mit klaren
Positionen gegen den Mainstream wir
schalten mal kurz rüber zur Vock WM das
ist jetzt also sozusagen der neue Sinn
also es ist halt wieder ein absoluter
Wahnsinn
diese
Woche Kultur ist in sich rassistisch für
mich der Bogen Wahnsinn des Tages viele
Insider erinnert das an den
erfolgreichsten amerikanischen
Nachrichtensender Fox News nur dass dies
können und Zuschauer haben in
Deutschland schrecken vor allem die
Werbekunden vor sowas zurück wenn ihre
Damenbinden oder Joghurt Schokoladen
plötzlich nach rechts oder links riechen
oder wenn keiner zuguckt für kaum
messbare 0,2% Marktanteil verbrannte der
Sender in 14 Monaten mehr Geld als
Christian Lindner an einem Tag deswegen
zieht Springer nun seiner saftbirne den
Stecker 80 Mitarbeitende haben künftig
wieder mehr Zeit zum Fernseh gucken und
spätestens hier ist jetzt die Stelle vor
der Oliver wecke mich vor der Show
gewarnt hat Alter man macht keine Witze
über schwächere da tritt man nicht noch
drauf also Respekt adjöbelt live die
Grand Dame des deutschen behämmerten
Fernsehens wir werden dich vermissen
aber Springer zieh dich warm an die
heute-show kommt wieder als Zeitung
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen